we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a caller concerned about what a Trump boot
edge, edge general election would be like.
Take a listen.
Hi David.
Loved the show.
Uh, I was just wondering, so hypothetically
if [inaudible] were to win the nomination
somehow, do you think that he would be able
to hold his own against Trump?
I kind of don't think so.
You know, I think that he has proven himself
to be unable to face harsh criticism.
Especially, you know, if you look at the criticism
that he received from Clovis Shar and you
know, declaring victory before Iowa was officially
called and so on is he's very milk toast.
And I just think that frankly Trump would
fry him like an egg on the sidewalk.
I just wanted to get your take on that.
So listen, here's the thing.
The debates are never as one sided as people
imagine that they're going to be in advance
of the Trump Hillary debates.
Many of us thought Trump doesn't know anything
about policy, and Hillary knows so much she's
going to crush him.
And I believe she won every debate on substance.
But there's always so much more to it.
And the perception of these debates very often
is everybody thinks the person they're planning
to vote for one.
You've got some exceptions.
You've got enlightened people who say, I'm
voting for a, but B, sort of got the better
of the debate.
I share with you concerns about what the dynamic
will be between Trump and some of the other
candidates, but, uh, it will never be as lopsided
and one sided as we predict, because there
are so many people who are going to see the
debates through hyper-partisan lenses.
So we'll see what it's like.
But it's not going to be the way this color
is suggesting.
If you disagree with it,
let me, let me know.
We've got a great bonus for you today.
Become a member or patron to get instant access.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].